i've had enough requests by now for
videos on investing that i thought i
would make some videos on
investing
investing and the way i'm going to go
about it is over the next few videos i'm
going to give people the vocabulary of
at least how do you think about
investing and and what are the the terms
and the ratios people use and why do
they make sense or why do they not make
sense and when do they apply and when
they not apply and then we're going to
use those tools later on and then
hopefully we'll look at some particular
companies and my goal you know it isn't
to do what they do on cnbc and you know
tell you buy buy buy and sell sell sell
because frankly you'll you know it's
that's not a that's not a thoughtful way
of going about things what i want to do
is really give you the tools to come to
the conclusions yourself and maybe you
know through the videos we'll come to
conclusions but i don't want to i don't
want to be too strong about them because
if i'm wrong i don't want you to lose
your your 401k so the first thing that
that
i guess you could say bugs me a little
bit is i go to these family gatherings
and you know some uncle or or aunt will
come up to me and says hey you know i
just made a killing i bought citibank
it's so cheap it's only
i don't know what it was at the time it
was only one dollar it's a cheap stock
as opposed to and you know implicitly
there there's the assumption that a 10
stock would be expensive and i think
this is very obvious to you but let me
let me write that down so price per
share
price
per
share
and so when someone tells me that a one
dollar stock is expensive they're
implicitly saying well that's just
because it's a low number as opposed to
say a ten dollar stock
10 stock let's call this stock a
stock a
and stock
b
and i think this is very obvious to
anyone hopefully who spent any time
investing or thought about
what a stock even represents but you'd
be surprised i've had you know family
members who are
doctors and engineers tell me this so i
thought it's it's a good place to start
to clarify any confusion so my question
to you is is something that is one
dollar is that cheap relative to
something that is ten dollars in in the
everyday world it is if if i could buy
an apple for a dollar that's cheaper
than an apple that cost ten dollars or
or any good really
but what and and the the twist here is
that a share is just a share it doesn't
somehow represent the entire company
it's a fraction of the company it's just
a share
and all companies don't have the same
amount of shares
for example
for example if i have
one company
and actually maybe that's a good point
to introduce a balance sheet
let's say one company whose
assets because i want to do this
throughout our discussion
whose assets are worth
let's say 1 million dollars
that's its assets all its buildings and
its employees and its brand it's worth 1
million dollars let's say and i'm going
to let's say it doesn't have any debt
and we'll introduce debt later because
that's another variable that a lot of
people don't think about when they look
at stocks they just look purely at the
equity value or the market
capitalization and all of these terms
we'll hopefully get very familiar with
over the course of these videos but
let's say its assets are worth a million
dollars it has no liabilities so all of
its equity that the asset value is all
in equity
so
this is all equity
sometimes called stockholders equity
and the equity is really just what the
people who own the company what is their
stake so in this case they never
borrowed any money to buy these assets
so the owners of the company own all one
million dollars if if you believe that
this is really worth one million dollars
now you could have this scenario let me
actually draw the same scenario over
again let me copy and paste this
let me copy and paste that so this is
these are two equivalent companies
completely equivalent companies
but this company over here they might
have decided to do that i don't know
they might have decided to have 10
shares it's about to draw the t
1 2
4 5 6
7 8
9 10. i think that's 10 shares well
that's my intention they have 10 shares
so what is the value per share right
each share in this case once again if
you believe that the assets are worth a
million dollars are going to be a
million dollars and the equity is a
million dollars because it represents
there's no debt so all of the assets are
are held by the equity holders so each
share would be worth a million
divided by 10 which is equal to one
hundred thousand dollars obviously you
never see a hundred thousand dollar
shares out there or at least not uh not
not in in in the great majority of
examples so this is a bit of a an
artificial example more likely a company
might have a million shares in which
case this would be a one dollar stock
but anyway this is a case where they
only have 10 shares it's a hundred
thousand and let's say this company
right right now right here so you know
100 000 that's kind of a crazy number
for share price it'll keep a lot of
people from buying our shares so let's
just divide it into a million shares it
is you know really so they have
times 1 million shares
so in this situation the company is
worth what it's worth or the shares are
worth what they're worth one million
divided by one million shares or one
dollar per share
so going back to the idea when my you
know family member would come to me at a
party they would say oh look how cheap
this company is compared to
this company even more let's say for
whatever reason because not so many
people could afford this stock because
just the you know just just to just to
get in the game you gotta put up a
hundred thousand dollars to buy a share
let's say this stock trades down and
it's trading at fifty thousand dollars
right it's trading at fifty thousand
dollars
and their assets are identical so this
is you know obviously there's no two
companies that are identical in this way
but let's say that they are let's say in
both cases the assets of this company
are worth the exact same thing as the
assets of that company
so here
investors are valuing this company at
one dollar
times a million shares they're valuing
these assets at one million dollars
in this case the investors are saying
okay i'm willing to pay fifty thousand
dollars per share and there's only ten
shares so they're valuing the assets at
five hundred thousand dollars and this
is of course the market value of the
assets and we'll talk more about market
versus book value of assets but the
market value of assets is essentially
what is the market saying the asset to
worth the book value of the assets or
what the accountants within the company
are saying the assets are worth and and
there's a there's a whole methodology to
how one would account for that but this
is the market value of the assets
and i already told you that these assets
are identical they they generate the
same earnings stream with the exact same
risk so in this situation you're paying
five hundred thousand dollars for the
same asset that over here you're paying
one million dollars for the same asset i
don't care what the actual share price
is this is what you're valuing it at so
the person who says that one dollar here
is cheap relative to fifty thousand
dollars here and they might even say
well they're the same company and i get
it here for a dollar a share and i get
it there for fifty thousand dollars a
share this is the cheap company that's
completely 180 degrees in the wrong
direction wrong because you're actually
paying more for this company you're
paying one dollar for one millionth of
this company while you're paying fifty
thousand dollars for one tenth of this
company so this one is actually the
better deal so in general when you're
trying to just figure out relative price
of a company and we're going to talk a
lot more about ratios and how do you
know if something is inherently cheap
relative to its earnings or what it
could earn or its growth or anything
like that but the first cut is you can't
just look at the price the price is
almost a meaningless number it matters
to some degree for trading purposes for
a lot of institutional funds won't look
at a stock that's below five dollars a
lot of stocks that go into the penny
stocks uh that's very uh i guess the
it's there's a lot of frictions in
investing in penny stocks because
obviously if you have a ten dollar stock
a ten dollar stock could go from ten
dollars to
ten dollars in one cent or it could go
to
nine dollars and ninety nine cents and
this is what this is only a a point one
percent move right but if you have a
let's say you have a penny stock let's
say you have a stock that's at five
cents
it can't move it can only move
by penny one in one direction before it
was actually it was actually an eighths
so if you move only by a penny you could
only go to a six to six cents or you
could go to
four cents and so in either direction
you're looking at a twenty percent move
well here you're looking at a one uh one
thousand move or or point one percent
move so that's one reason why price
might matter a little bit here there's
huge frictions if you were to buy and
sell you're kind of you know there's 20
changes every time and we'll talk about
things like bid-ask spreads and
liquidity and things like that in the
future but that's where the price really
starts to matter and obviously if you
have a really huge price like a hundred
thousand dollars that makes it difficult
for people to buy even one share
but that's that's the only place where
price matters inherently when you're
talking about value you have to take the
the price per share and you multiply it
times the number of shares
number of shares
so these stock a and stock b these are
different than the ones i drew down here
so let me draw a little dividing line
right there and let me erase
some of this because this is for a
different
let me see let me erase that
so if in this example let me actually
erase more
let me erase
this as well
all right
so in this example
it's important to write down the number
of shares you have
and you could look this up on yahoo
finance and we'll do this in the future
with a bunch of companies we'll just go
through the motions of figuring out all
of the metrics just because you you kind
of have to need that's a good starting
point just to get a sense of what the
company is all about so let's say that
this company has
10 million shares
10 million and this company right here
has
i don't know let's say it has
500 000 shares
500 000 shares so what you do is you
multiply these numbers to figure out
what is the market value or the market
capitalization of the company so that's
a word
market let me write that down
market sometimes called the market cap
market
capitalization capitalization
market capitalization and you multi and
it's essentially just what what is the
market saying the equity is worth right
and in this case or i went off the
screen in this case where you don't have
debt they're actually saying what what
is the asset worth
so if i took this one one dollar per
share times a million 10 million shares
the
market is saying this company is worth
10 million dollars for that the equity
of this company is worth 10 million
dollars in this case they're saying 10
per share times 500 000 shares they're
saying it's worth five
million dollars that's the market
capitalization of the company that's
what the cup the
this is what people are saying the
company is worth
and actually i'm running out of time
from there so in the next video we'll
talk a little bit about well how does
how do people actually determine what
something is worth and and that
obviously can be a infinitely deep
discussion but we'll try to get get our
feet wet a little bit see you soon